don't get close to them wild turkeys are
not considered native to California most
of the state really turkeys are not a
problem but there are certainly a local
problem particularly in some residential
areas that have high quality turkey
habitat turkeys were brought in
primarily for hunting and I think as you
understand the whole turkey issue you've
got to think that in that time that was
probably you know not considered a
particularly controversial thing
probably considered a good thing
the first known release of turkeys in
California was in 1877 on Santa Cruz
Island by cattle ranchers beginning in
1908 the department started releasing
birds that were raised on game farms in
1949 and 1952 the department first
experimented with releasing wild turkeys
that were trapped in the wild and
translocated and released in the wild
about 1959 the department brought in
turkeys from Texas Rio Grande subspecies
and released them in San Luis Obispo
County the department from 1959 all the
way through 2000 had a consistent
program really throughout the state and
those are the birds that we primarily
have in California today it's in really
only in about the mid 1990s did it start
becoming something that was
controversial
you know the downside of it are some of
the nuisance concerns that have
developed particularly in residential
areas in the state and there are some
concerns about their potential impacts
being a non-native species to the
environment native flora and fauna
and some of the residential areas it
tends to be followed up with enjoying
the turkeys let's feed them once you
start feeding them you almost can't get
rid of them they become like stray cats
so we very strongly advise people not to
feed turkeys as we would with really any
wildlife turkey hunting is the obvious
solution that comes to anybody's mind in
areas that you have turkey problems the
problem is some of these areas that
folks want to get rid of Turkey's
hunting is just not feasible because you
can't discharge weapons for very good
reasons in those areas started hunting
turkeys in the early 80s turkeys weren't
around back when I was a youth and grew
up they weren't around until my early
20s when I first started there actually
was very few turkeys in California they
were very very hard to find we now have
some we're almost around 30,000 turkey
hunters in the state of California one
point six nine million dollars just
buying the upland game bird stamp and
just buying their license it takes fuel
to get there it takes groceries it takes
water in the field if each hunter spends
$100 a day that is an estimated 20
million dollars put back into the
economy in California in the springtime
so I think you think that beard is 5
inches probably about I would say 9
inches on that beard nice nice long
beard for your first gobbler I actually
think the people complaining about wild
turkeys is somewhat silly because if you
want to live in the world you're gonna
have to put up with the grass growing
with bees with mosquitoes with all types
of wildlife the benefits the what it is
brought to California the one on one
that you're able to spend with your
children in the field
the the economic benefits that is
brought to California way outweigh a few
little nuisance
on Thanksgiving Day the United States of
America will consume an estimated 46
million turkeys
a recent study concludes that a typical
turkey feast for eight people produces
approximately 44 pounds of carbon
dioxide emissions